[MUSIC]
Put this piece here and
then take this one and put it here.
Hi there.
Have you ever felt like building
a web application is like making
something with tiny pieces and
no instructions at all?
JavaScript is flexible, so is the don
which makes browser application
development feel like assembling
a million tiny pieces.
You don't have to do this alone though.
Front end frameworks such as Backbone,
Angular, and Ember
handle the common details so you can
focus on what makes your app special.
So welcome, I'm Richard Kalehoff,
a course developer at Udacity and
a front end application developer.
I'm excited that you've decided
to come on this journey with me.
Let's discover the amazing capability
that front end frameworks provide us
developers.
In this course we'll be taking
a look at the major features
of client side single page
applications and some SPA frameworks.
We'll work our way up from Backbone_
then build the applications
with other popular frameworks.
By the way, people have asked
us why we're not covering react.
React is an incredibly popular library
for quickly updating the dom, but
it only really handles the view,
not the whole application.
We're focusing on the complete
application framework.
Once you've completed this course,
you'll be in a great
place to learn react.
When you finish this course,
what will you be able to do?
You'll be able to slip right into
working with popular job script
frameworks.
And you'll also be able to evaluate
frameworks to see if they meet the needs
of your new project.